au relais de chanteloup les vignes on
récolte 15 à 16 tonnes de vêtements
chaque jour ici on trie à la main le
linge à recycler ou à redistribuer un
peu partout dans le monde au premier
abord une entreprise bien loin des
technologies de pointe et pourtant
depuis quelques années déjà le relais
utilise le m to m le machine to machine
un système qui permet à des objets de
collecter envoyés et traiter des données
sans intervention humaine alors qu'on
fait on est une balise dans le véhicule
sur la partie avant est donc on a une
transmission de données et donc grâce à
ce retour là on va avoir grâce au
logiciel
l'information sur les coordonnées x y
avec leur précise la quinzaine de
véhicules et géolocaliser les trajets
connu en direct tout comme l'avancé de
la collecte
donc voici le planning journalier de la
collecte avec l'ensemble de nos
véhicules qui sont donc
notez sur le côté gauche chacun a donc
un certain nombre de collecteurs à vider
dans la journée lorsque le collector
donc
évident et la case et grises et donc on
connaît donc l'avancement de la tournée
et puis donc tous ceux en orange sont
des collecteurs reste en restant à vis
des autres applications du m to m des
sondes cachés dans les containers le
système nécessitent encore d'être rodé
mais devrait permettre à terme de
connaître le taux de remplissage est
d'organiser la collecte plus
intelligemment ça nous permet
d'économiser gagner du temps de
rationaliser nos tournées et qu'on parle
de rationalisation on est du coup sûr
moins de déplacements donc en coups et
puis en en bilan carbone c'est
évidemment meilleur au relais le m to m
permet donc de gérer la flotte et la
collecte mais de nombreuses autres
applications sont possibles économies
d'énergie gestion de stock ou même
maintenance de coeur artificiel le m to
m englobe tous les secteurs